قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان سفن
وطائرات الدول المنضمه الى المبادره
الامنيه التي اعلنها وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لويد اوستن تستمر في الانضمام الى القوات
الامريكيه في البحر الاحمر واضاف كيري ان
هذه العمليه هي مبادره امنيه متعدده
الجنسيات ستقوم باجراء المراقبه البحريه
واتخاذ الاجراءات الدفاعيه لحمايه السفن
من خطر
الحوثيين
اعلن منسق الامن القومي جيك سولفن ان
الولايات المتحده ستحشد المجتمع الدولي
لمواجهه الاخطار المتزايده للحوثيين على
الشحن في البحر الاحمر هذه الهجمات يجب ان
تتوقف فهي غير مقبوله الولايات المتحده
وحلفاؤها سيفعلون كل ما عليهم فعله
لمواجهه الاخطار الارهابيه التي يشكلها
الحوثيون في البحر الاحمر لحمايه السفن
epri